I came to this video playing grim a sub
cycle cowboy Simon Williams that is the
ginger gem its nickname chatter some
super sharp player this name cycle
Cowboys yeah not to UM to better choice
okay the bogo some interesting that he
goes for that relatively tame kind of
opening a swatch so can get a really
close position surprisingly enough this
is not exactly the type of position that
he excels in so let's let's see what
happens okay let's check that
yeah I don't mind that this pawn
structure change my queen side is quite
secure now and I still have the five
idea so just drop back be sure be 4i can
also just go nitey six so right okay and
now let's go F for attending Bishop f5
interesting yeah okay Queen B seven
rupee Edwin's the Queen's Own this he
cannot do trying to get them get this i
exchanged should i play should I play
night to g6 not really Bishop age three
mmm now he might take at the end on be
sapna mean it's not okay this is just as
a bit of a gamble I might take and play
night g 526 or instantly okay but night
here is some also a bit of a
double-edged thing it goes 96 I've f3
check the light squares on I really weak
okay night takes chest from the night x
Queen takes sorry we take something so
the question is watch now it's not turn
threatening much I can go to g6
intending night eh form mmm yeah the
question is if i go here he takes f8 I
think I can't play night h4 this is a
draw hmm i don't know if i have more
here I can play for more they are
probably not
so not f8 night a choicer draw takes
Queen g-form with a perpetual check if
he takes I don't think I can recapture
with rook and just play on it so it's
not not enough him okay he wants to hide
which is probably the right decision so
I can still play g'nite to h4 and
probably force a draw
hmm for if I move the rock that is going
to play group III night this also Queen
B 7 at the end okay not much not much
choice I need to do that check check no
no Kings you want us to draw kingi too I
think oh no I cannot sacrifice easily I
thought I can sacrifice on f 2 but and
even win but this is not true okay but
this cannot be the end of the world here
it's it should be a good attack anyway
what I overlooked is rook takes King
takes look at that you can take with the
with the night I should have a good
attack anyway
hmm
you know the chick here doesn't really
amount to much to always king d 1 Jack
probably just the check I don't don't
have anything better
mmm this looks more than risky but I
don't see I don't see a reputation at
the moment check this out this is
possible
rookie three days afore check
check
Kingda form cannot believe that it still
plays it check
hmm sure that there must be some some
major Queenie five mages a threat
light-weight an idea yeah this is just
one threat and probably who hmm yeah we
both thought that I'm meeting but he can
actually just take it the computer gives
white a slight edge here ah what a crazy
game that is and I probably missed a ton
of wins earlier takes rook e1 and there
is no checkmate check check this is the
computers line just saying that why does
a bit better okay so let's check how I
could have one okay it is an easy draw
but he didn't want to draw he just tried
to okay how the computer says that Jack
can do that this is this is surprising I
was really sure that there should check
yeah this is so good for wide according
to the computer and they tend to trust
the computer in such a position this is
amazing it looks a completely working
check to do that but it seems to win for
what Wow check
yeah this this loses to do to King see
to check I actually thought that okay in
this position I will have something but
there isn't there isn't anything yeah
okay this is just shows her how
difficult it is to to play with the bed
king check c5 know black is winning but
I need to take with the pawn Queenie six
is a mistake okay need to do that Jim
okay they are probably just threatening
all this c5 Queenie six yeah okay this
is a wicking but isn't this amazing that
my moopheus is bad form for black due to
this with this king this is so so weird
yeah what a strange game he was totally
irritated and resigned so funny okay
thanks for watching